Speaker 2: All right. Let's get in to audience
emails for the week. You can email info at David
Pakman. Dcoms. Sometimes tweets or Facebook
messages or YouTube comments may be included.
Let's just get right into it because there's so
many to get through today. You know, one of the
funny things that happens every time we stream
a Trump rally is people who have no idea about
our channel or anything. They'll just kind of like
come by because they're looking for the rally and
then they'll see, Oh, here's someone talking
about it, that's me. And then they'll realize
I'm not saying positive things, and then they get
really mad and they will start emailing. So as you
can see, this one in particular happened during
a recent rally on a Saturday and Landon wrote in
and just does in all caps, we love Donald Trump.
You are. And then that was the end of the email.
Apparently they accidentally sent it. So then they
follow up and they say a bum. They meant you are
a bum. Pack it up, loser. And then a little
bit later, by the end of the thing, they say,
I can't wait until the Patriots cancel you and you
need to get a real job. Get a real job, commie.
And this is pretty common. Of course, this is
not a communist show and this is a real job.
And in fact, I think that lots of these folks
have no clue what is going on when it comes
to independent media. But I always appreciate
them coming by and contributing their, you know,
increasing the view count by one, increasing
the comment count by a couple. So thanks,
Landon. Monty wrote in also during a recent Trump
rally and said, you are a stupid s.o.b. You think
dumb ass Biden is good for this country. When we
are paying $5 a gallon under his administration,
$5 for a loaf of bread. Eggs are twice as much now
than when Trump was president. I could on and on
about the inflation under Biden. I also live by
the Mexico USA border and I've never seen so bad
as it is now. Crime has doubled under Biden and
on that subject I could go on and on. I came upon
your show by accident and I'm glad I did, because
now I can use you to show my liberal friends just
how stupid they are. When Biden is not trying to
introduce dead people, he's wrecking our country
with the support of idiots like you. Well, Monty,
I'd appreciate you sending some of those folks to
my channel. We're trying to get to 2 million
subscribers on YouTube, so, yeah, send them
my way. I would very, very much appreciate that.
Julia wrote in about my commentary last week about
lefties and masculinity and the poll that found
that young women are moving more to the left,
but young men are not. And Julia said, I
thought about your segment today on the
young women becoming more leftist as opposed to
young men staying where they are. I agree with
you that many men simply don't admit to others
that they're on the left. And the reason could
be backlash from the right leaning friends
and family. Just look at these crazy right
wing nuts calling you gay pejoratively without
any reason, solely based on political opinion.
Keep doing what you're doing. Best of luck to you
and your family. Yeah, I think that Julia is more
or less spot on and it more or less also echoes
the comments that I made last week. You know,
there's been this sort of cartoonish stereotype
of what masculinity is supposed to be under
the Republican Party. And what's really funny
about it is that Trump. Has espoused that idea,
and so have many of his followers, despite
Trump himself not actually being that. In fact,
being very much the opposite in many ways. And
that's because the facts don't really matter.
It just it doesn't really make a difference to
them. But that is the sort of picture that they
have designed. And it's not a new picture. Right.
I mean, when we talk about they want to go back to
the to the 1950s, part of what we're talking
about are those quite rigid views, in fact,
on on gender and femininity and masculinity.
So I think I think Julia is definitely on to
something. Here's another message a Trump missing
documents a while back when this was breaking
someone on MTV. I don't know what that is.
Speculated about them being in Ivanka's casket,
the documents being in Ivanka's casket. Now, I
think what the person means is Ivana's casket.
Ivana Trump recently died. It was all about the
same time. And she noted that it took ten strong
men to carry the casket, which supposedly
contains her ashes. She was mostly joking,
but the more things move along, the more it seems
plausible. Don't they have some ground penetrating
radar they could use to check it out? Listen, I
have heard all of these different hypotheses about
Ivana was buried, where she was buried, I guess,
at or near some golf course for a tax deduction.
There are documents in the casket. There are
burned up documents. And I have no idea. It's
really not super interesting to me. There are so
many other things going on. It's speculative. I
don't know that we would ever really find out if
something like that was going on. My thought is,
I don't want to put too much of my time into
that, but I know that there are many people
who have been speculating about the details of
Ivana Trump's casket. I will leave it to them.
Luke wrote in and says, Thank you. Hey, David.
Just want to say thanks for all of your work
on the show. Congratulations on 1.5 million
subscribers. I've been listening to your show
for about three years now and much more engaged in
politics than I was before I started listening. I
used to be sort of an apolitical independent who
thought both left and right were equally bad. I
guess we call that enlightened centrism. Okay.
Over the past few years, I've started to realize
how the radical how radical the right wingers have
become in the Trump era. And consider myself very
left leaning now. You certainly have had a big
influence on that change. You also have a talent
for clearly communicating ideas that is all too
rare, which I find myself emulating to some degree
in my job as a teacher. Keep up the good work.
You're making a difference. Here's to 2 million
subscribers. You know, it's so rare that we
just get, like, a nice email of that kind
that I love that and I love featuring it. Johnny
Rhode wrote in and says, There are multiple Oh,
how many followers on Twitter have you lost?
There are multiple, countless of reporting
of users that are reporting that they have
lost tens of thousands of followers. Have
you lost many or any? I don't even follow these
people and never would writing an article about
it now. Yeah. So when it the first time that it
was announced that Elon Musk was buying Twitter,
tons of right wing accounts gained a ton
of followers and some left wing accounts
lost some followers. I lost some. It wasn't
really clear. Why was it people leaving the
platform? Joining the platform? Because of
the news, I guess. Then it looked like Elon
Musk wasn't going to buy Twitter. Now that
again, it's looking like he might buy it.
There were I lost four followers on the day of
that announcement. Now I gain followers every
day like you go you go back hundreds of days.
Every day I gain followers. So losing any is
weird. I don't really understand it. Maybe it's
that on the news of Elon buying Twitter again,
a bunch of left wingers said, I'm not going
to be on a platform owned by Elon Musk. So
they they quit. They canceled and deleted their
account, I don't really know. But it was very,
very minimal, at least on my end. Edward wrote
in about current gas prices and says, David,
sir, why is it that Republicans no longer talk
about gas prices? Pretty obvious. I just think
it's funny how Republicans only pin gas prices
on Biden when they're high. To be clear, I'm in
agreement with you. President doesn't control gas
prices in either direction. I just find it funny
how Biden is only associated with high gas prices
in their mind. Love your show, Edward. Well,
Edward's wrong about one thing. It is true
that many of them are just not talking about
gas prices anymore. Many are talking about them
and lying. Trump keeps saying they're so high and
they're going even higher and he'll use numbers a
little bit less now that gas prices are down. The
other thing is, over the last few days, they've
actually started to tick back up. And again,
these very same people who have been totally
silent on it for weeks now, months, in fact,
are now back to talking about the gas prices.
It's the same circle. It's worthless. It's really
not worth much of our time. They're going to do
their routine no matter what's going on with gas
prices. I say we just move on and focus on more
important things. Eight. He wrote in and asks Why?
Says Trump's most likely going to run for
president again. My question is, why would
someone enter a race and expect to win when they
know the other side's cheating? If he enters the
presidential race, it is a total admission. He
never believed the race was stolen. Not quite.
The logic here is good logic, which is if
Democrats have it all rigged. Why would
any Republicans even bother to run? Why would any
Republicans even bother to vote? Because Democrats
are just going to steal it. The way they get
around this, as they say. If enough of us vote,
it will overwhelm the voter fraud. And so we can
still win, even though there will be some fraud.
That's how they kind of close the illogical loop
of logic that they've created. They say, yes,
there's going to be fraud. It's rigged, they're
cheating. But if we have a big enough margin,
we'll end up winning by a little bit after all
of their cheating is accounted for. I know it
doesn't make any sense. It's completely wacky,
but that's their argument. That's what they claim.
Info at David Pakman dot com. Get your questions
and comments requests for corrections. I'm glad to
entertain an even a little bit of trolling. Not
too much, but a little bit of trolling. We have
a great bonus show for you today. Sign up at join
pack mint.com. You'll get instant access instant
and then if you are not part of that group. We'll
be back Monday with a new show and of you the.